I'm a debride I'm a reporter now I
always seem to find myself questioning
something the government may not be
looking at I found something really bad
I have been taking
look around in the world who do you see
a planet on the brink of collapse
human beings are disposable but man and
symbiote a mind this is a new race your
species the higher life-form
[Applause]
we cannot just hurt people
we have a deal so many time
to that power it's not completely awful
you have no idea how much you're scaring
me right now a wobbly
and you just might survive guys you do
not want to do this trust me
we'll always come at a cost
bleep you are relaxed and everybody to
face right up ahead you will be this
almost weightless faith with big review
rolling down the street
[Music]
oh I have a parasite yeah
neighbors chant
[Applause]
you